Speaker 1: So after heckling Joe Biden during
Tuesday night's State of the Union address,
yelling out when Joe Biden was literally talking
about his son that died Lauren Boebert yelling
out in the aftermath of that, she sort of
got a hero's welcome and a lot of different
places, and she was interviewed by Turning
Point USA is Charlie Kirk.
Now, if you don't know Charlie Kirk and you
don't know Turning Point, I envy you.
But in all seriousness, it's a very well-funded
organization that is pulling in young people
to radical right ideology, and they do it
very, very effectively.
Charlie Kirk interviewed Lauren Boebert, and
she defended her actions, saying, Listen,
I was very caught up in the emotion because
I am so worried about the troops that died
under Joe Biden.
Take a look.
Speaker 2: And so I think you are a drill
baby drill shirt as well yesterday, and a
lot of the state of the Union is theater.
So now I got to ask you, Congresswoman, because
we've been receiving a lot of emails and some
of our listeners are divided.
I think you could probably see part of why
they're divided because we really went after
Nancy Pelosi when she tore the speech.
We said, have some respect for the president.
What do you have to say for people that say,
Hey, look, I'm with you, congresswoman, but
maybe you shouldn't interrupt the president
of the State of the Union?
What's your thought on that?
Speaker 4: First of all, I was really caught
up in the emotions of it.
Speaker 1: Right, so first to right off the
bat, she basically is saying it's like a moral
get out of jail free card.
It was.
It was a moment of passion.
It's sort of like you killed someone.
Well, it was a crime of passion.
I wasn't thinking she was so caught up in
the emotion that that's supposed to be like
a blanket excavation for what she did
Speaker 4: in mentioning Afghanistan, but
didn't bother to mention the 13 soldiers.
He went on to something totally different
and totally different.
Speaker 1: Yeah, his dead son totally different.
Speaker 4: Really just overwhelmed me, and
I couldn't help but speak out and look.
I would love to have a conversation in a better
setting with him, right?
Speaker 1: And the way to get such a conversation
is by heckling him when he talks about his
son who died.
And that's, you know, Kyle Rittenhouse the
other day, he said on some show we're going
to we might sue Joe Biden.
He might get a letter.
It's like, Oh, really?
Why?
Well, he's like, Yeah, well, I asked him to
meet with me five times, and he didn't.
And it's the same type of idea here.
She would like to meet with Joe Biden, but
Joe Biden hasn't met with her, so she heckled
them while he was talking about dead soldiers
and his son who died.
And and now he's going to meet with you.
Speaker 4: I would love to be able to talk
to him, and maybe I'll get the chance to do
that when Republicans are in the majority
in twenty twenty three and we can actually
put forward my articles of impeachment for
Joe Biden and have a real conversation.
Speaker 1: Yeah, you're not going to you're
also not going to have a conversation with
Joe Biden if you put forward your silly articles
of impeachment, which she and Marjorie Taylor
Greene have been talking about now for months.
Speaker 4: And as far as the drill baby drill
goes, Joe Biden, he waged a war on American
energy and left us in a very dangerous place.
We rely on Russian energy, importing nearly
six hundred thousand barrels of energy per
day.
Speaker 1: Now I want to talk about this a
little bit.
A very popular talking point has become we
were energy independent under Joe Biden, and
now we are not.
The data is widely available.
We cited it in our story about energy independence
a couple of weeks ago.
For the last several years, the U.S. production
of oil has matched US consumption of oil.
Now you have to understand that under Biden
and under Trump, even though that's the case,
there is still trading going on.
And we send some oil abroad and also bring
some oil in.
But in terms of the numbers, for several years
now, we've produced as much oil as we've consumed.
So the idea that Joe Biden has done any drastic
thing, we're now we are not at that same equivalent
level of production and and use is just a
lie, and she keeps repeating it.
No one challenges it.
It's not true.
When we should
Speaker 4: be energy independent and certainly
energy dominant, we should be able to export
energy to our allies, which is literally exporting
freedom.
And so I wore drill baby drill on my shore
to remind the Democrats of exactly what we
should be doing.
Speaker 1: No one cares about that and how
we
Speaker 4: should stop funding Russia's war.
Speaker 2: Yeah, and that's that's a lot of
the State of the Union is kind of like making
alternative points.
And I think people understand that.
And I'll be honest, like if I was in the audience,
I don't know if I would have been able to
contain myself.
So I think that's a that's a fair answer.
If I had to listen to Joe Biden, go on and
Speaker 1: Charlie Kirk would have done the
same thing.
So there's this soft defense of the completely
indefensible and they're they're not going
to stop, they're going to continue doing it.
And unless these folks are just removed or
forced to behave differently, they will continue
escalating and it's not going to change.
And that shouldn't surprise anybody.